that space we think it's an exciting day
to think about those kinds of things
especially because it's election day all
right we're very excited to kick off
today with moon duchin who is also on
our panel yesterday so moon is a
professor of mathematics at Tufts
University where she runs the mgg
districting lab and she's going to tell
us today about some really cool
redistricting work that she does great
hi can you hear me okay
um so I have 45 minutes followed by my
esteemed collaborator alone who just
snuck out
um and so my goal is to introduce you to
this problem and set up his talk he'll
be talking about our joint work on uh
differential privacy and redistricted so
um okay and did you did you all vote oh
please
um I am so terrified about today
um it'll be really interesting to see
what happens all right so
um
before I start I want to just plug two
things so one is there's this math
Institute right up the hill from here
like up by Tilden Park called msri
mathematical Sciences Research Institute
it's in the process of a name change
that will also put Simon's into its name
confusing everyone
um and um it has two programs next fall
algorithms fairness and equity and
market and mechanism design and I'm one
of the organizers for the algorithms
program you can apply this month apply
by December 1st for post-docs or faculty
visits and please come it's going to be
a fantastic program
um ask me about it if you want to know
more about anything to do with that also
my lab M and many G's which is the
metric geometry and gerrymandering
groups that's what it stands for we're
hiring a postdoc this year and I love to
collaborate and so there are I'd love to
talk to you if anything I have to say
today intrigues you let's let's talk
more
okay so before I zoom out and explain
redistricting from scratch I want to set
up the problem with what I like to call
the sad story of Republicans in
Massachusetts my home state
so here's the motivating question if you
stop and you think about how blue is
Maryland how blue is Massachusetts you
you might have said
um if I had you guessed before I put the
numbers up you might have thought
Massachusetts was Bluer but actually if
you look at presidential and U.S Senate
contests over the last 20 years they're
very similar Maryland tends to vote 36.9
percent Republican in those contests and
Massachusetts 36.7 almost the same but
then if you look at the Congressional
delegations that each state sends here
are the delegations from Maryland from
1994's election down to 2018 just didn't
get around to adding 2020 to the bottom
but it's similar
um so red is Republican and blue is
democratic and the seats there are
numbered so Maryland has had eight seats
this whole time is it clear what the
notation is here
um okay and here's Massachusetts
okay um which had 10 seats until the
2000 census and then dropped to nine
um okay so
um the that that share of Republican
votes is being converted to 28 percent
Republican representation in
Massachusetts and none at all in
Massachusetts this is my proudest Emoji
achievement ever
what's going on
um and so you know what I'm setting up
is the problem of redistricting how the
districts are drawn so the way this
works is after the census comes out
um particularly with its redistricting
release called the pl 94 171 it's all
the tables that you're going to hear
about from Phil a little bit later
um the um the states then must divide
themselves up territorially into
districts and each of those districts is
going to conduct the plurality election
and so the question is does the design
of the boundaries impact the outcomes
and the answer is of course it could
and when you take advantage of the
control of the lines to advance an
agenda we call that gerrymandering and
so this sure looks like gerrymandering
and then we can wonder whether this is
gerrymandering or not because for most
of us our intuitive ideal would be
parity between the share of votes and
the share of seats that's called
proportionality in this space right so
This falls short of proportionality but
this is a total lockout so it looks like
an extreme gerrymander
but this turns out not to be what's
going on here
so this is an actual vote pattern in
Maryland I know that the quality is not
that good but I think you can see the
colors right
um with 34 Republican won't share that's
an actual election and this is an actual
election in Massachusetts with 32
Republican vote share and of course they
look very different to your eye and so
what's going on is the what I call the
geometry or what you might call the
political geography like where are
people located
um and what you can see is that you know
there are the rural parts of Maryland
vote quite Republican but at least for
the for a certain time period in recent
history Massachusetts had no Republican
enclaves right and so I like to describe
this by saying you know there's about a
third of the state voted for republicans
and about a third of every County and
about a third of every town about a
third of every Precinct that's what
you're seeing in the picture is
precincts and maybe a third of every
household right and if that's true then
it doesn't matter how you draw the lines
you cannot make a district that will be
won by a republic so you get a forced
lockout that isn't a function of intent
right
um and so I wrote a paper about this in
the election Law Journal where we
actually smuggle the theorem and a proof
into the election Law Journal and I was
pleased by that
um and what we did if you think about
this as a computer scientist this is
kind of a knapsack like problem we asked
ourselves the question what if you had
total control and you relaxed the rules
and then keep relaxing the rules a
little more could you make a republican
District if you really tried and we
proved that you could not
okay for a span of 10 years in recent
Massachusetts history the actual
election observation the pattern of the
vote
um made it impossible and it's a fun
little theorem actually
um it made it impossible so there are
more ways to redistrict Massachusetts
than particles in the galaxy and
everyone gives a nine zero sweep okay so
this just sets up the problem that I
want to talk about today which is the
question of redistricting as a math
problem your intuition that if you just
weren't trying to steal power you'd get
something like proportionality is wrong
um it's the most wrong in Massachusetts
but it's a little bit wrong everywhere
right and that's that's what you need to
model because it's not obvious and it
has it it sensitively depends on this
kind of spatial distribution across a
network in an interesting way
questions yeah
um
one woman can we please take all of our
questions on the microphone for the
recording of resume thank you this is
about getting exercise for the
organizers as they run around yeah
someone from us you just do like a high
level guess as to why Massachusetts is
so weird in this way oh but it's just
it's just what you saw in the picture
we're like like why historically
well it's less and less true which is
interesting so if you look at the bush
Gore election and the Clinton Trump
election those are to a decimal place
the same percentage of Republican
support but the picture looks really
different
um lately there are more enclaves
um but it was extremely flat I mean you
know there's something interesting to
say and let's talk more later but New
England's you know I talked about
President and Senate election that
didn't talk about Governors we love our
Mitt Romney's for governor right in in
Massachusetts and in our Charlie Bakers
so there's yes I have a lot of thoughts
about the sort of whys and where fors of
the political geography but for this
project the question is given an
observed political geography what is
possible um but yeah let's talk more
about that
okay so
um so now we'll zoom out to the basic
problem having motivated it that way and
the basic problem is about dividing up
territory
um and we're going to try to do that in
a population balanced way and I'll talk
more about population balance as we go
um most American elections are single
member districts with plurality it turns
out not all and that's kind of
interesting fourteen percent of state
legislators today were elected for
multi-member districts fun fact
um it's sort of surprising if you think
about
um you know our image of American
democracy we can talk more about that
too but I'm not going to do the social
Choice thing I'm going to focus on this
style of election and try to understand
what's happening and the question is how
much Advantage can you extract under
this set of rules
okay so you know this is just the
cartoon that says gerrymandering it's
real
um so these three are the same city with
a three to two cat lover to dog lover
split and if you know where the cat
lovers and the dog lovers live then you
can make balance districts with anything
from two to one dogs to all cats right
um and so this is not actually this is a
cartoon this is literally a cartoon
um but this is not so outlandish as a
representation of what's possible in
realistic political geography as I'm
happy to explain
so let me situate you heard about this a
little bit yesterday on the panel but
just let me situate this with my
experience so I like to model this and
also my lab builds technology for this
process so
um I worked with commissions
legislatures and redistricting boards in
a whole bunch of States these are some
of them in this cycle
I'm also an expert witness in lawsuits
around redistricting in seven states now
Georgia is on tap
um and the goal here in all of this work
is not to replace districts but to build
them better and understand how they work
and to Benchmark them
um all right so let's talk about the
modeling
um so just just very briefly here's the
plan you say thank you to the U.S Census
Bureau for partitioning the territory of
the U.S so exhaustively and then you
take the the units usually from the
Census Bureau sometimes from the state
and you use those as the tiles that make
up a state so you might use census
blocks you might use precincts the
redistricting program at the bureau has
something called vtds which are like
snapshots of precincts and those are
very very useful
um so where possible I like to use the
Census Bureau geography because it's
less contested than the messy stuff that
comes out of States
um then you can take once you've picked
some units you can just create a network
dual to the tiling by which I mean a
Vertex for each tile and edges for
adjacency and this is the graph that we
want to partition so we're going to be
trying to take this network for a given
State and partition it into a certain
number of districts subject to certain
rules
um okay so here are the actual this is
the actual dual graph or the barycentric
embedding to U.S census tracts from
2010.
okay continentally yes and uh here is an
actual picture of the 432 continental
U.S congressional districts in September
2019 it changed the next month they
change all the time because of
litigation
and so put those together and you get
like a colored graph right you get an
assignment of the nodes to districts and
this is the kind of partition problem
that I want to study except I won't do
it for the whole country I'll do it one
state at a time okay
um
so
I want you know yesterday we talked
about objectives and constraints I want
to tell you a little bit what those are
realistically and redistricting but
first I want to issue this very
important disclaimer it is a mistake to
think about redistricting as an
optimization problem or constrained
optimization problem it is not that
um what I'll try to explain is that we
have objectives we have constraints but
we also have by design by constitutional
design a lot of latitude for the line
drawers to take other legitimate
considerations into account sometimes I
call this the Grandma's house principle
it's fine if someone is drawing the
lines really wants to create a lump in
their District to put Grandma's house
into their District that's fine as long
as it doesn't have too much cost to the
other priorities so you see how it's not
really an Optimum this is a mistake that
technical people always make when they
start thinking about this is to think
about it as an optimization
um however let's still look at the what
are called the tdp's traditional
redistricting principles
um I call these the big six
population balance we'll talk more about
that
something called compactness which just
means the shapes should
be nice and some very vague way we
shouldn't have really disgusting fractal
looking districts they should be plump
and you know tame I'm a geometer so I
love this one this is a fun one for me
um contiguous which just means the
pieces should be connected
um respecting counties and cities and so
on this is often called respect for
political boundaries but this is what it
means
often the way it's written in the law
will say you should your District Lions
should follow county lines but really
what they mean is try not to split these
typically what is meant by that
this is a nice really big and important
one respect communities of Interest so
where you find people that have a shared
interest that is Salient to their
political representation you should try
to keep them together or in some other
way amplify their voice boy that's vague
right and so for instance a real example
from Georgia I think he's Georgia as an
example real example from Georgia is
like the onion farmers and the peanut
Farmers have different needs right and
like knowing where they are and sort of
keeping them together in a district to
amplify their voice matters that's a
real example from
um and then last on my list but not at
all least is racial fairness another
difficult one to operationalize
um via
um the federal Voting Rights Act of 1965
and other pieces of the Constitution
we'll talk more about that
questions at this point
other than how in the world could you
put that into a quantitative framework
that's the big question uh okay so let's
talk some more about some of these so
first let's talk briefly about
population balance and of course there's
an infinite amount of stuff to say about
this and I have a short time so I just
want to say enough to kind of give you a
sense of the richness of the problem and
I'm happy to talk more I'll be here
um all week uh as they say in Vegas
um so one personal one vote that's
jurisprince that comes out of the 1960s
so before that the Federal Government
Federal Judiciary was extremely
reluctant to get involved in districting
at all
um famously Justice Frankfurter said
it's not only a political Thicket but a
mathematical Quagmire he was really
right about that
um but finally the court did get
involved because they took it to be an
equal protection so the 14th amendment
guarantees equal protection under the
laws and the idea that you might dilute
the vote of one group was an equal
protection violation so it was worth
wading into the thicket slash Quagmire
to try to handle that
that gave us a series a pair of Court
decisions Bakery Carr Reynolds V Sims
1962 and 64. that produced this slogan
actually it was originally one man one
vote but we've modernized right um one
person will vote and what that meant was
population should be balanced across the
districts because it was a
malapportionment when some just at the
time some districts were 10 times as
populous as others yeah more than 10
actually but that was they were sued
over
an example like that
it's pretty obvious that the weight of
your vote your vote goes further if
you're in an underpopulated District
relative don't overpop him
okay so what does that mean though
um to get a concrete meaning out of one
person one vote like what is being
equalized exactly and how it took time
and a whole series of further cases
here's an important one Karcher if you
dag it from 83
um because you know I'll just say before
going into what this says the standard
today is to take that redistricting data
hot off the census presses
and to equalize the population across
the districts not the adult population
not the citizen population not the
registered voters but the total
population which includes people who are
undocumented includes all kinds of
people in principle
um why that's the standard basis could
be a whole other story and it's a very
interesting one uh ask me about that in
the questions if you want to talk more
but that's That's the basis typically
um affirmed Again by the court in 20
2016 I think it was in Evan Welby Abbott
that's still this that's still the
default although there's a lot of
pressure on other possibilities
um okay so once you know that that's
going to be the basis then you can say
well how good does the Census Data have
to be right we all know since it's based
on ostensibly a complete enumeration
door-to-door complete enumeration but in
a huge country which has you know
pandemics and things that's very
difficult right so we know that there
are going to be systematic under counts
and over counts in the Census Data
um how perfect does the data have to be
for us to treat it as the truth for
redistricting so the court has weighed
in on this a few times this I like this
quote they say even if we can't be sure
that one district is bigger than another
just because the census told us so we
can say that with the district with a
larger Census count is more likely to be
larger than it is to be smaller isn't
this a great uh yeah looking over it our
census representative but this is good
this is this is nice this is just saying
that like the numbers are good enough
that what looks bigger probably is
bigger
okay and then here's another decision
from 2003
that introduces a term that I think is
really important this term of a legal
fiction basically what this is saying is
that the data is good enough it's the
gold standard it's the best thing we
have the data is good enough that it
should be treated as perfect truth even
though we understand that it is not
perfect it is suitable to be treated as
perfect by the people making the
decisions this is really important I
think also this is a lovely idea for uh
stem people I think legal fiction that's
great it's and this is this is a term of
art
um it's something that is suitable to be
treated as truth it's like declared
ground truth right okay
so this is this is the legal framework
around one person one vote and how does
it actually play out
this is the start of uh the National
Congress of State Legislative National
Conference of State legislatures it's
terrible ncsl
um their table from the from 2010
redistricting and what you can see is
when it comes to Congress the most this
is wild but true the most common thing
is for states to balance their census
population to within one person from one
District to another that's an insanely
stringent interpretation of one person
one vote
um some states have kind of the right
for legitimate State interests they they
can go for a slightly bigger deviation
but these percent deviations are teeny
tiny so congressional districts are
incredibly tightly balanced on census
population and if you look at State
houses and state senates
um typically the top to bottom range is
is well under 10 of Ideal District size
which is still pretty tightly balanced
you'll see exceptions that are
interesting like Hawaii is made of
islands and keeping Islands whole is
important so they have bigger deviation
for that reason so basically you can
have a reason to have more deviation but
the balance is usually pretty tight so
just to Flat you know to sort of set up
the conversation later about noise in
the Census Data you can see that one
source of anxiety is if we introduce new
noise into the Census Data can we still
uphold our bizarre fetish for one person
deviation
will it will if we think the districts
are balanced will they be balanced right
that's one question that people have
asked
okay that's all I'm going to say about
population balance now let me introduce
the Voting Rights Act which is this
racial fairness law that
um sets up two of the other worries
people have had about differential
privacy
so this is the signing ceremony for the
VRA that's LBJ that's MLK these are
Natalie dressed civil rights organizers
um and so this law was passed
resoundingly in 65 it was only supposed
to last four years originally but it got
extended and sharpened and it's like the
most important redistricting law in the
land these days
um it was designed to sweep aside some
Jim Crow era devices that blocked black
people from voting in the South
specifically poll taxes literacy tests
and so on
um
and then its scope was expanded
um many times over the 57 years since
then uh today it's on the chopping block
at the Supreme Court and at 510 I'll say
a little bit more about that
so what does it say that matters for
this talk
um well
uh first of all broadly what does the
VRA say it says that
if you have any device or system that's
making it harder for minority groups to
elect candidates of their choosing
then it should be replaced by something
that provides more opportunity if
possible
that was what the original act says it's
extremely vague and so to use it it
required Decades of clarification about
how you were gonna understand those
roles and how you're going to test them
in 1986 there's a decision Thornburg V
Jingles that gives us for kind of the
first time a pretty precise
quantifiable framework for how to use
this law you guys following me so far
how it's pronounced angles it is yes
yeah you'll embarrass yourself if you
get up and talk about gingles factors
yes
um
okay so um actually and you know a
question was asked on the panel
yesterday which was how do academics
best interact with kind of this world of
social considerations as it's
constructed in this conference this is a
fascinating example usually when the
Supreme Court
tries to build a framework they do it
based on the briefs they got from the
attorneys or sometimes amicus briefs
Friend of the Court briefs that they got
from others in this case they lifted the
straight out of an academic paper Okay
so that's where this came from this was
a law review paper by blackshire and
Menifee from earlier that decade
so here's the rule these are three
threshold conditions before you can sue
under the Voting Rights Act and the
first one is
um it has to be the racial or language
minority group has to be sufficiently
large and geographically compact to
constitute a majority in a single member
district you should think about this as
an existence proof
can you draw a plan where your group say
black voters in Georgia is a majority in
another District in other words can you
draw an additional majority black
District does that make sense
okay
um
then you have to show what's called
racially polarized voting which is that
the minority group tends to prefer the
same candidates so they have coherent
candidates of choice but they're blocked
by the majority
okay so this now today we run fairly
standard stats packages called
ecological inference and ecological
regression to demonstrate that you have
this kind of polarization
and this like I said was always just an
existence proof draw a plan that has an
additional majority minority District
importantly hugely importantly this is
just threshold conditions for a lawsuit
when you actually get in the door and go
to court you are under what's called
totality of the circumstances and you
can talk about the history and you can
talk about all kinds of political
factors and can talk about everything
everything's on the table at the end of
the day if you win the lawsuit you don't
have to draw majority minority districts
this is so important to understand you
just have to draw districts that provide
opportunity and I can tell you like for
instance I testified last month in South
Carolina where you can draw a district
that gives black voters in South
Carolina an effective opportunity to
elect with as little as 20 black
population you absolutely don't need
majority black to get opportunity this
is a threshold test to launch the
lawsuit and historically nothing else at
the end of the day this isn't the remedy
this is just a step to say yes a lawsuit
can be you know
one here
annoyingly it earlier in uh Bartlett V
Strickland which was a case in the Arts
in the 2000s
um the court was asked did you really
mean majority didn't you just mean an
effective opportunity and in a John
Roberts author decision they were like
no no we want 50 plus one right we
really mean numerical majority so this
is now a really weird framework because
like I said if in South Carolina you
only need 20 and appropriate crossover
voting and a strong candidate to have a
chance to win why should you have to
draw another 50 District but this is the
law
okay questions yeah
uh for the first Factor can it be like
two related groups or two groups that if
you're can I gerrymander two groups at a
time and then this is a good question so
um what is a racial or language minority
group well the VRA was originally
conceived for black voters in this house
that was the original conception but it
got significantly expanded over time so
now it could be any racial or ethnic or
a language minority and it's been used
for example in Lowell Massachusetts
close to where I live there was a
coalition claim on behalf of Asian and
Latino voters uh they got a consent
decree there I am a expert in Texas
where
um our plaintiffs group is a coalition
of black Latino and Asian voters in
Texas but the law around these Coalition
claims is hard and the current
legal climate is forbidding
um but yes in principle you can make a
coalition claim but then for Jingles two
you have to show that your groups
actually vote together right
other questions
okay so this is the other two worries
that civil rights world had about
differential privacy they were worried
that
um what seemed to be a majority District
sometimes you have to slice it really
thin to get your majority district and
would differential privacy make it
harder to prove that it was actually a
majority district for that racial group
and they were worried about this if
we're now doing statistical inference
such as linear regression that it uses
race data from that's been noised
is that going to attenuate the signals
of polarization
right okay so now I've set up the three
major worries
um is population really balanced is a
majority District really so and are we
able to detect polarization when it's
present after noisy
um I just wanted to say um what time
that I have left
um so this framework was hugely
important and we probably know this as
technical people if you want to use
rules it really helps to make them
precise even if as we saw in the last
slide they're sometimes made precise in
a silly way they're still made precise
and so it's easier to use so you see
here you know the end of the Civil War
is over here and then the 13th 14th and
15th amendments and then you get a blip
of black representation that's what
we're doing on this slide this is a
cartoon by the wonderful Olivia Walsh by
the way
um you get some black representation in
the South right after reconstruction and
then comes this long repressive violent
period of American History called Jim
Crow which was designed to end that
black representation and
um
we get the period called The Great
Migration when uh black people in large
numbers move from the south to Northern
cities Philadelphia Chicago and so on
and so you start to see some black
representation in the North
but it's not until the Voting Rights Act
that you that black representation picks
up from zero in the South again and then
uh here's Thornburg V jingles and then
you see this huge increase because the
law becomes much more usable now that
it's been made more precise
okay
all right so um
I just wanted to say that the legal
status quo is a bit of a conceptual mess
um so briefly in the 90s
people started to the the court started
to think about these rules and started
to worry that like if you're a majority
minority District
had to be really ugly and non-compact
then maybe that was not
a good that maybe race had predominated
over other traditional concerns they
worried and so here a majority black and
a majority Hispanic districts were swept
away as unconstitutional because they
were ugly
it was they literally they called it a
beauty contest and they were like we'd
like to not have Beauty contests but
nonetheless these districts are just too
bizarre irrational they give these kinds
of words for ugly right
um and so these were swept away but
Justice Stevens and his descent was like
well you didn't touch those majority
white districts
right so it the status quo legal setting
is confused it is muddled
um
but
um what's happening now with a newly
emboldened and extremely conservative
court is that as I say on the slide uh
you know what has been chipping away at
race conscious policies in government is
now becoming like a really like a sea
change that's going to eliminate the
possibility for race conscious remedies
uh and and so even this kind of
equilibrium that we've been in for the
last few decades is not going to last
okay so yes
how do you as a geometer quantify that
this is ugly is this kind of like um
what is a perimeter divided by area is
that kind of okay so there were the two
most free when I started working I
started I've been working on this stuff
for since 2016.
um uh election season in 2016 kind of
got me interested in this and now this
is like taking over my research program
and the in if you if you read expert
reports to the court there were two
dominant scores for shape and one is
isoparametric
inequality you know ISO parametric ratio
so um area over perimeter squared as
you'd expect if you if you assaulted a
mathematician in the street and made
them pick that's what they'd pick right
um and the other one is I really dislike
that's popular it's called the react
score and the react Score says and I I
went back and I read the paper by Ernest
riac and when she introduced the score
he said well we know that circles are
isoparametrically optimal
so let's just measure how close it is to
a circle very strange reasoning so what
what react wants us to do is to
circumscribe
um the shape just draw the smallest
bounding Circle and take the ratio of
that circle's area
and that's called the react score these
are two of like 35 scores that were
lying around in in like various
Publications in political science and
geography
um I I think they're all pretty silly
partly because you know Texas has some
Coastline right or think about China
redistrict in Maryland
um all these scores have Coastline
problems and like sort of they don't
make good scores if you want to take the
ratio and interpret it out of context uh
so I introduced and now it's great to
see this new ish
for you guys there's this other really
obvious thing you could do I'm about to
just say it it's you'll be like yeah of
course and now it's starting to be used
in court cases this I think this is this
pleases me and that is well if we're
going to use the census geography if the
units are really you know if the if a
plan is really about assigning census
geography just look at the size of the
cut set
in the network
right
um so that's starting to make its way
into court cases now which I'm pleased
by um we call that the cut edges score
it's totally obvious right but um it it
mitigates the coastline problem
um and it kind of is based mostly on
what's relevant which is the assignment
of a given set of units right okay I
don't think it solves all the problems
here actually one of the research
findings
um from the modeling I'm going to show
you on the next few slides is that
um compactness does much less than you'd
think to constrain the ability to make
an extreme gerrymatter
so I I still think it's important and
I'll explain why but
um it's much less constraining than I
expected when I started working on this
okay
um thanks for asking okay so we're now
we're going to model this we're going to
ask can computers deliver whatever a
race neutral Baseline a partisan neutral
Baseline can computers tell us what it
would look like if we weren't
gerrymandering
um okay so the dream was initially that
uh and this you can find in in
operations research journals and law
reviews in the 1960s
um the the dream was just okay write
down the criteria and then make all the
plans
all the partitions and just sort of
score them and
profit right
um but of course we can't do that
um so we this turns out to be not only
is full enumeration intractable but even
uniform sampling is intractable it turns
out you can't build an approximate
uniform sampler for this problem unless
RP equals MP your problems
okay so there are complexity
obstructions even to uniform sampling so
we're going to try to sample but we're
going to try to sample against some
other probability distribution
okay so let's do it here we go so you
might think that this is a good way to
go
um to just set up so the colors here are
districts I started with vertical
stripes and I'm flipping one note at a
time a lot of statistical physics but
this doesn't work great because you can
see
a constraint that's very important here
that is not present in like
classicalizing models in physics is we
want the districts to stay connected and
so it's actually I'm I can't flip
something in the middle without
disconnecting the district so it's
actually really hard to make big changes
this way even if you wait a long time
make sense
okay and this is just showing you that
on Kentucky these are the block groups
of Kentucky if you start out and even if
you try like some simulated annealing
and you'll let the boundaries get wild
for a hundred thousand steps and then
you cool down and make the boundaries
shorter you'll end up roughly back where
you started
this just doesn't work very well hey
moon on the last slide which is maybe
addresses here
um
um like it is a problem that you you
began with stripes and if you began with
blocks would it yeah no that's just
really dramatizes it but that's why I
was showing you this realistic example
this is this is just flip chains don't
work because reasonable plans are kind
of well separated in the space in the
state space and it's just really hard to
get from one reasonable plan to another
by this procedure
um it's such an interesting problem
there's a lot of rigidity here this is
this is like my happy place so I'd love
to talk about this more but I don't have
a lot of time right now
um but no it's not that was just for for
drama okay but so here's the alternative
that
um uh Elle Knight who's a student
working with my research group
um said let's use spanning trees and
then we kind of ran with that and so
here's a recombination procedure using
spanning trees which I'll explain in a
second and I have a survey paper about
it with Deford and Solomon
um how does it work it says all right um
here's a nice thing to do when you want
to partition a graph
um build a spanning tree and if you cut
that spanning tree
um you cut the graph into a controlled
number of districts this is a nice fact
if you delete a Vertex from a tree you
could have lots of components but if you
delete an edge you have exactly two
components
right so um we'll make spanning trees
and delete edges in order to to build
the districts
and I'll briefly mention I I know I
don't have time for this but there's
um there's some new first of all there's
new things to prove about spanning trees
which is fun
um but one thing you could do for
instance if you think back to those
rules that said keep counties together
you can nudge your spanning tree
construction to to keep counties
together by putting weights on the edges
of a graph with Edge's internal to
counties having lower weight than edges
external to count you know between
counties and then use a minimum spanning
tree construction and that's going to
tend to keep counties together so just
from a like theoretical computer science
point of view this is a very Nimble
efficient construction with lots of
customizability which is fun ask me
later
um okay so how do you use this is just
my very brief
kind of
PostScript of how you use it so here's a
recombination Markov chain running on
Pennsylvania
and if you want to use it to analyze
plans here's the legislature's plan from
2011 which is ugly
here's the legislature's do-over plan
after they were sued which is compact
spoiler alert it's just as bad right
here's the remedial plan that was
selected by the court and put in place
and this was made by an eighth grade
class
um this year in 2018 in this litigation
the governor of Pennsylvania hired me to
consult and like advises veto which was
my first foray into the Practical space
super fun
um and once that press release went out
this eighth grade teacher sent me this
plan by email so this is this is real in
the wild eighth grade class and so what
is the
the Markov chain let you do you can
collect all the plans that are visited
by that random procedure and make a big
Ensemble or big collection of plans and
then you can ask the question how many
Democratic seeds should I expect if the
plans were drawn without a partisan
agenda
and the answer is you know and so this
is like the Massachusetts question so if
you did this in Massachusetts there'd be
one big spike at like all the seats
would be Democratic because every plan
that you built would have all Democratic
seats and that would give you a sense of
the Baseline you guys with me
in Massachusetts is Extreme in most
other states there is a poll
away from proportionality but you have
to it's an empirical question how big
that poll is away from proportionality
so here it is in Pennsylvania in blue
are a hundred thousand plans encountered
by the random algorithm
in colored dots are these four plants
and so this shows you how big so there
is a kind of like the mere rules in
geography Advantage Republicans
significantly in Pennsylvania just as a
function of where people live and how
partitions work
but that if you took the presidential
voting pattern from 2016 that effect
would be like
two seats off
and if you took the Senate voting
pattern from the same year it would be
three seats off this is just an
empirical question you can't guess you
have to model
okay and then the color dots show you
you see how the red and yellow dots are
in the same place in both patterns this
plan looks nice but it behaves just like
the other one
whereas the one adopted by the court is
very swingy five seats for Democrats in
this pattern eight seats for Democrats
in this pattern
uh and the 8th graders behave just as
though they did not have partisan data
by sitting at the highest bar
okay
so that's the model and then I'll just
close by saying like what does the court
have to say about all this it's really
interesting how this has played out so
in 2019 the court was proposed this kind
of thing as a way to adjudicate partisan
gerrymandering and they said whoa whoa
first of all they stipulated that this
was relevant and like kind of doing
something that got at the right
questions but they said how far is too
far anyway like down a bell curve like
how how far away is really the problem
we can't tell there's no bright line
this must be too hard for federal courts
so the decision in 2019 said partisan
gerrymandering shall now be okay
nationally because we can't decide where
to draw the line
and then shockingly right now they're
like wait a second we love this if
instead of adjudicating party partisan
gerrymandering if we can use this to end
the VRA all of a sudden like this is
really suddenly manageable as a way to
think about racial gerrymandering and so
this many people say this is an example
of ends oriented
um
um
decision making
um because the courts being faced now
with the idea that maybe racial
opportunity should only be deserved when
you can get it at random
right and so the fact that I've been
kind of telling you emerges in these
models which is that often uh minority
gets significantly underrepresented by
random districting all of a sudden is
appealing if it means less entitlement
for Effective districts for racial
minorities yeah okay and um all right so
I'll just close
um we can't find fairness this way we
have to kind of decide what fairness
means
um all this stuff tells you is the
central Tendencies of the rules given
the geography if you don't like the
consequences you have to change the
rules cough cough social choice
um
Dan
thank you
I'm out of time I ordinarily would take
questions but let's just pass it to
alone and then you can maybe ask us both
questions at the end yeah why do we take
one question while alone he sets up if
there is a question
um okay at the end of the I mean at the
beginning of the talk you mentioned that
during the last 20 years this setup in
Massachusetts have been pretty much like
that but that
um that we're seeing more enclaves form
over time and I'm wondering how fast
how fast do things actually change and
how does that how much does that matter
yeah
it's a great question
um the political geography in Missouri
has changed really fast in 10 years we
used to be a purple State no it's a
bright red
um in Massachusetts what's interesting
is that the overall percentages aren't
changing just the just the locations
and
polarization
um there are lots of if you ask me about
lots of other states I have lots of
other views
um but I'll say this I of all the states
I've studied which is wrong
um there's only one where the bell curve
is actually centered
acroportionality it's interesting and
that's Regina
um and I think one of the reasons is
that Virginia doesn't have big cities
but how small cities scattered all over
and since today's polar partisan
polarization looks very Urban rural in
character that's one of the reasons that
there's a kind of lack of
there I guess only says we have time for
one more question sure okay
I
don't have to run today
other questions
okay great let's thank Moon again
[Applause]
our next speaker is alone